can we talk about the time frame and the
conversation that you had with howard
about developing or redeveloping
the script for skin in the game because
he saw it he said
i like it but yeah yeah so howard had
liked it and he
had uh uh there was no commitment there
was no commitment that he was gonna make
it
there was no i mean we were just doing
the dance if you will you know
and at the time because it was
benefiting the script and because it was
becoming better
i was like okay this this works you know
what i mean but i didn't know if he was
going to make it or not
i didn't know at the end of this journey
so i was still
sort of you know still trying to find a
way to do it independently
like if you will like i was still trying
to raise a hundred thousand dollars here
i thought maybe we could have done it
for three hundred two hundred thousand
dollars so i was like okay well maybe at
one point i'm thinking we can do a fifty
thousand dollars
so i was like because i was just you
know
i was yeah i don't know if i was i'm not
gonna use one of these word desperate
but i wanted to make a movie like i
wanted to make a movie right
but you got to be careful with that word
desperation because that desperate
causes you to rush a script into
production
being desperate causes you to uh oversee
like over overlook certain things like
the script may not mechanically work or
maybe have problems but she's like oh
god i just got to make this movie
so desperate is not a place you want to
be
you know you talked about being on set
sometimes and you just don't want to be
that guy who's
or girl woman who's on set being
desperate you want to be calm about the
whole thing right and so i had peace of
mind during the whole process
but i didn't know if he was going to
make it or not and so i was looking for
other
at that time probably you know seeing
how we could do it for a hundred
thousand dollars or whatnot
um and it was it was a year i mean you
look up but you know a year goes by kind
of fast
like you're like uh wait a minute three
months have passed you know you do a
rewrite
two months to pass you give him a script
it takes him a month to read it you know
then he gives you back he calls you
there's notes
then he travels he's hey boom he's
he's at a sundance film festival you
know so then that month is down
and then he comes back and then he has
to gear up for this commercial thing so
it's like
i'm working so it doesn't feel like a
year but a year goes by
right before before we make the movie
yeah and the script is constantly
getting better
and it's constantly evolving and we're
constantly in communication and talking
you know about you know you know what it
could look like
and yeah so then sending him revisions
and then he gives you notes yeah i was
sending revisions he had had uh
uh mike nell is uh is over there he's a
co-producer over there and
mike would give us notes i would go
sometimes i'd walk in we'd sit down we'd
talk
they'd both give me notes we could
change this whatever we think about this
and it was never like
dictatorial you know they would just be
making like like suggestions
you know i think it would be better if
we did this and blah blah because howard
in his company they really
i think they protect or they they
respect
the vision of the filmmaker right so it
wasn't like they were trying to change
my vision at all it was
always about like how do we make this a
better house this can be a better house
this can be better what if we add this
what if we take this away
you know like uh the ending was a big
was a big thing for us
you know because sundance and usually
independent film
usually like places like sunday like
darker endings
right they like gritty endings and so
you know we played with the ending a lot
you know but then i think
there was uh who told me this yeah one
of my survivor
women told me don't make it uh
a dark ending she told me even though
the reality for most of these girls is
they don't get out right a lot of them
truthfully either succumb to drugs you
know
uh they get worn out and they uh
some of them die you know i mean you
know the lifespan of a prostitute is
only like
seven years yeah and so you know or the
od so it becomes it's like a very
grim experience and so but she told me
do not
show the ending so in our movie i don't
want to give away any spoilers
but there was a point where the hair uh
the lead girl gets caught into the life
and doesn't come back
but this person the survivor told me she
said don't do that because she says
the pimps will use it as a recruiting
tool
and they'll use it to say look see she
couldn't get out
you see see this movie this is the truth
this is your reality so don't even try
and everybody it really it meant
something to me so i shared that with
howard and them too you know and uh i
think it
impacted all of us you know in terms of
the way we shaped the the movie
toward the end yeah did anybody
try to talk you out of making the movie
in that they thought maybe you can't get
distribution
because of the subject matter
distributors might be scared of it
yeah well that's that that's where
howard was key but
i remember one of our first meetings and
he repeated this
a lot he said listen this can
move you after we finish it it can be a
paperweight
it can uh it can be an exercise of
futility
it can sit up there on the bookshelf
there it's just uh you know
um you know just it's like just
collecting dust
right it may go nowhere right he was
very real
i mean like i was like i mean you know i
mean i was like
you know like because that's that wasn't
my thinking right at all
but he had again he's an experienced
producer and he's done this a number of
times
and then when we met again we were
getting ready to make the movie he said
listen this can either sit on the shelf
it can be a paperweight
or it can be an exercise of utility like
he said that exact same thing
and um do you still want to do this you
know
and i said yeah you know and
but see he had been to the other side of
the mountain he had been the journey
before so he knew
right so even now as we get skin in the
game out there to audiences
and it's been a great journey it's been
a great journey right um
but we didn't get into sundance we
didn't get into tribeca
you know we didn't get into toronto uh
we didn't get into south by southwest we
didn't get into
any of the top tier festivals right so
that was a whole year because if you
know anything about festivals they want
to premiere your film
first the top tier ones if they don't
get access to your film
first like say if you premiered at
chicago international film festival and
then sunday and say okay we want your
movie
we want the exclusive rights to the
premiere and you're like well we already
premiered it
at chicago they're like well we don't
want it
so that happens a lot so you have to
um gauge it and we had to go a whole
like almost cycle year
of trying to get into the big festivals
then when we didn't get into the big
festivals then we could back up and say
okay we didn't get into
all the big ones right and why do you
want the big ones because the
distributors are there
because the buyers are there because the
national press is there
right the attention is there so you want
to hold out for those festivals
but when you don't get it then you say
okay now what are the second tier
festivals
and uh so we were fortunate i mean we
were fortunate in the sense that we
premiered at urban world in new york
in september which is a great festival
you know we had a great
premiere there then we went up to uh
whistler film festival in canada
and then we ended with the pan african
film festival and we won best director
best first feature film right so yeah it
was uh it's been a journey
but to your point about how we're
talking about the paperweight but now
we're in the process is distributing it
right and distributing it is almost as
hard as making it
like when you ask yourself what is the
hardest part writing the script
making it or distributing it i'm almost
like
well distributing it is hard as hell
because now you got to get it out there
to people people have to see it
you want people to see it and so um
yeah it takes it's and we're an indie
film so it's like ch choo choo choo choo
choo
yes you can yes you can choo choo choo
choo choo you know
so plus it's not as sexy to be
distributing it yeah
when you're on set oh yeah you're you're
even though there's stressful moments
and then you made another point about
the subject matter so howard was also
very clear
this is this is not a popular subject
matter
or a lot of people don't want to see
that kind of thing it's in the shadows
right
and so even my wife for instance never
read the script
even when we finished the film she never
saw it and she was actually when i was
writing the scriptures like how can you
write that how can you you know i mean
it created something for her in terms of
just the subject matter
and we had two little girls so it was
and i understand it
right and so i knew just translated from
that to what howard was saying
it's not gonna be an easy sell
and you know for whatever reason people
are not gonna
just be it didn't matter how good the
film is just to be drawn to the subject
but i would say i'm willing to roll the
dice
in spite of all that he said let's roll
the dice
knowing what he knew is a businessman he
said let's roll the dice yeah
it seems like you're attracted or you're
willing to
explore dark subject matter and and
know that a lot of people may not want
to see
they may know about young children
working in mines
and it's horrible but i do i really want
to spend years
why do you think you're willing to go
there well because
as much as you talk about the dark
subject matter and the darkness
of the uh why do i go there i'm an
optimist
and so i like to see the light in the
darkness you know sometimes i think the
light is
in the darkness right and so
i'm gonna go there because i'm still
fighting for the hope and the
possibility right
so i'm never going to tell a story where
it's just dark
right and then at the ending it's it's
like unconscionable
and you know i'm always going to there's
going to be a spin on it
right or there's going to be a take on
it so in the diamond mine
thing you know we got the kids out of
the mines you know we funded them in
soccer
and we put them in schools so that was
like there was there was something that
came out of that
right and so with the girls it was
important for me to tell the subject
matter
but it was also important to tell that
one story of possibility and hope
you know the girl that made it the girl
that did get out
and so we can cling on to that you know
so i'm not afraid of the darkness
but you know for me it there has to be
that um
that thing where i'm not gonna just live
in there just you know
wallow in it yeah there's got to be some
um
some hope some possibility so i'm always
fighting for the possibility in the hope
you